Scrabble boy! Scrabble boy! Give me a word that starts with an L. Call me Scrabble boy. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 89 recorded on July 25th, 2022. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce Bryce, we continue part two of our two-part conversation on Carbon, the Programming Language. If you haven't caught part one, I would definitely go and listen to that first. Oh, right, right. You were talking about all the complexity of writing a simple C++ function these days where you have to add in concepts where no except, you have to write everything. And I think that pair example is a perfect demonstration of that. And, you know,
拼字游戏男孩！拼字游戏男孩！给我一个以 L 开头的词。叫我拼字游戏男孩。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 89 期，录制于 2022 年 7 月 25 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起，我们继续进行关于碳编程语言（Carbon, the Programming Language）的二集对话的第二部分。如果你还没听过第一部分，我绝对建议先去听听那一期。哦，对，对。你之前谈到如今编写一个简单的 C++ 函数有多么复杂，你得加入 concepts、noexcept，你什么都得写。我认为那个对子示例就是一个完美的证明。而且，你知道，
perhaps with time, any language would end up like that. But I, it was a very compelling argument that we have added too much complexity to the language over the years by adding new features. I, as a committee member, I see lots of people online say that half of the Internet says that the C++ committee is adding too many things. Half of the Internet says that the committee is not adding things fast enough. And this is the first time that I really thought, yeah, maybe we are adding too many things or maybe it's not that we're adding too many things. Maybe it's that we're not doing a good job of them, of adding them. Well, his, he made a comment at one point, you know, that he just,
也许随着时间的推移，任何语言最终都会变成那样。但我，这是一个非常引人注目的论点，即多年来我们通过添加新功能，给语言增加了太多的复杂性。我作为委员会成员，看到网上有很多人说，半个互联网都在说 C++ 委员会添加的东西太多了。半个互联网则说委员会添加东西的速度还不够快。这是我第一次真正心想，是的，也许我们确实添加了太多东西，或者也许不是我们添加的东西太多，而是我们在添加它们这件事上，也就是在添加它们时做得不够好。嗯，他，他在某个时候发表了一个评论，你知道，他只是，
he just wants sometime in the next couple standards like preferably the most the one that's getting released the soonest he just wants a way to write a line of code and know that it'll get executed on a gpu he says today in c++ like you cannot know that or at least not like easily but but in c++, if you use parallel algorithms and you use NVIDIA's Nvc++ compiler, you're good. But yes, I did find that particularly compelling. And what Sean meant by that is he wants a way where you can explicitly say, run this in the GPU, whereas the parallel algorithms don't tell you that. The parallel algorithms tell you that, you know, you can request parallelism, but not on a particular execution context. But, you know, I do think that that is coming in the form of senders and
他只是希望在接下来的几个标准中的某个时间——最好是最快发布的那个——他只是希望有一种方法能够写一行代码，并且知道它会在 GPU 上执行。他说，在今天的 C++ 中，你无法确定这一点，或者至少没那么容易。但是，但是在 C++ 中，如果你使用并行算法（parallel algorithms），并且使用英伟达的 Nvc++ 编译器，那你就没问题了。不过是的，我确实发现这一点特别引人注目。肖恩（Sean）的意思是，他希望有一种方法，可以明确地表示“在 GPU 上运行”，而并行算法并没有告诉你这一点。并行算法告诉你的是，你可以请求并行性，但不能在特定的执行上下文中。但是，你知道，我认为这会以 senders 和
receivers. Like an explicit standard way of saying GPU execution context, that might not, we might not have that until after the core senders and receivers. But we are, we do have a plan for that. We do have a plan for that. But I completely understand Sean's frustration. This is a feature that will land in the the standard um you know a decade after it was needed like first needed and that's juxtaposed with his graph that he showed um both in the 2020-12 talk 2012 talk and this keynote talk that he just gave of the you know composition of compute um and it breaks down you know how much like where does the compute live and without breaking it down you know um
receivers 的形式到来。就像一种明确的标准方法来指定 GPU 执行上下文，这可能不会，在核心 senders 和 receivers 出来之前我们可能都不会有这个。但我们确实有这个计划。我们确实有这个计划。但我完全理解肖恩的沮丧。这是一个将在标准中落地的功能，嗯，你知道，在它被需要——首次被需要——十年之后才推出。这与他在 2020-12 年的演讲、2012 年的演讲以及他刚刚发表的主旨演讲中所展示的关于计算组合的图表形成了鲜明对比，该图表分解了，你知道，计算量有多大，计算到底驻留在哪里，而且没有把它分解得，你知道，
by every single thing he points out if you're just running a single core uh application like you're accessing like you know just literally like less than a percentage of the compute and like he said he didn't actually give an updated one because he said computers are too complicated with the way that they're doling out compute. But basically like back in 2012, I can't remember what the exact number was. No, no, no. His point was that if you showed the updated graph,
事无巨细，他指出，如果你只是运行一个单核应用程序，比如你访问的计算量，你知道，字面意思上还不到百分之一。正如他所说，他实际上并没有给出更新后的版本，因为他说计算机在分配计算资源的方式上太复杂了。但基本上，早在 2012 年，我不记得确切的数字是什么了。不，不，不。他的重点是，如果你展示更新后的图表，
there would be no point in it because the visual would, you would only be able to see the gpu oh was that his point yes all right that was his point i mean there there he did also make a point that with with things like um ml accelerators and with things like you know the the um you know ai flops um with that that are claimed by various uh companies including our own it is sort of hard to figure out how exactly to measure um compute these days do you just measure you know how many fp64 flops it can do do you just ignore the specialized hardware you know so i think that was part of his point.
那就毫无意义了，因为在视觉效果上，你只能看到 GPU。哦，那是他的意思吗？是的。好吧，那就是他的意思。我的意思是，在那里，他也提出了一个观点，即对于像机器学习加速器（ml accelerators）以及诸如人工智能浮点运算（ai flops）之类的事情，各种公司（包括我们自己的公司）宣称的这些性能，确实很难搞清楚如今到底该如何准确测量计算性能。你只是测量它能做多少个 FP64 浮点运算吗？你只是忽略专用硬件吗？所以我想这也是他观点的一部分。
But I think his core point was if you showed that graph today, the performance would be like 99% the accelerator. Right. In terms of raw flops. But, you know, most applications, you know, are just not going to access the raw flops capabilities. Most applications are going to be, you know, are just, are not going to access the wall-flops capabilities. Most applications are going to be, you know, some way memory-bound, either memory-bandwidth-bound and
但我认为他的核心观点是，如果你今天展示那张图表，性能的 99% 都会是由加速器提供的。没错。就原始浮点运算能力而言。但是，你知道，大多数应用程序，你知道，根本不会去访问原始的浮点运算能力。大多数应用程序将是，你知道，或者将不会访问墙上的浮点运算能力。大多数应用程序将是，你知道，某种程度上受内存限制的，既有内存带宽限制，又有
memory-latency-bound. In some cases, compute-latency-bound. I like to describe it as most applications are just a fancy form of memcopy. Most applications are just moving data around and maybe twiddling a few bits somewhere. And so from that perspective, what percentage of flops you can access maybe isn't the right metric. But certainly for something like Photoshop, which is a compute-heavy application,
内存延迟限制。在某些情况下，还有计算延迟限制。我喜欢把它描述为大多数应用程序都只是 memcopy 的一种花哨形式。大多数应用程序都只是在四处搬运数据，也许在某个地方微调几个比特。所以从这个角度来看，你能访问百分之多少的浮点运算可能并不是正确的指标。但对于像 Photoshop 这样计算密集型的应用程序来说，
that is what you would care about yeah so i don't think the keynote uh for sean's will be it might be available by the time this episode actually this one is i mean i hear that i think i'm pretty sure we know the conference program chair right so we should be able to to make sure that the video is posted when this episode is up. I mean, I don't have control over our technical people that are making the videos. I'm not saying you have control. I'm just saying you can send an email. Anyways, Carbon.
这确实是你所关心的。是的，所以我不认为肖恩的主旨演讲会……等这集播出时它可能已经有了。这一期，我的意思是，我听说，我想我很确定我们认识会议节目主席吧？所以我们应该能够确保当这集节目上线时，视频也能发布。我的意思是，我无法控制那些制作视频的技术人员。我不是说你有控制权。我只是说你可以发封邮件。不管怎样，Carbon。
Keynote. Yeah, so the Chandler keynote is online. Sean's keynote actually might be out because by the time part two of this comes out, which is the one we're talking in right now, it's very meta. It'll be roughly two weeks. So they might. And even if they aren't, we'll update the show notes as soon as they do go online. And by us, I mean me. And we'll link the YouTube channel so that you can just subscribe and get notified as soon as the talks come online.
主旨演讲。是的，所以 Chandler 的主旨演讲已经在网上播出了。肖恩的主旨演讲其实也可能已经发布了，因为当这集的第二部分发布时——也就是我们现在正在录制的这一期，这非常套娃——大概会是两周后。所以他们可能会。即使没有，一旦它们上线，我们也会更新节目说明。我说的“我们”是指我。我们会附上 YouTube 频道的链接，这样你就可以直接订阅，并在演讲上线的第一时间收到通知。
Anything else you want to say about Carbon? We will bring Chandler or a representative. You know who we should get? We should get Kate to come on next. Kate Gregory, for those that aren't operating in the C++ community because she was both attending, speaking, helping organize CBP North and is also on, what do they call it? She's one of the three BDFLs of Carbon.
关于 Carbon 你还有什么想说的吗？我们会请 Chandler 或一位代表来。你知道我们应该请谁吗？我们接下来应该请凯特（Kate）来。凯特·格雷戈里（Kate Gregory），对于那些不在 C++ 社区活动的人来说，因为她既参加了会议、发表了演讲、协助组织了 CBP North，同时也是，他们管这叫什么来着？她是 Carbon 的三位 BDFL 之一。
So she was on state. Nope, not BDFLs. She's one of the three members of the core team. I mean, can't we call... They are not benevolent dictators for life. The core team will be rotated and there's not one of them and they don't have absolute control over the project they can just decide between options that are presented to them they are in no way shape or form benevolent dictators for life so they're benevolent they're benevolent painters i think
所以她是 state... 不，不是 BDFL。她是核心团队的三名成员之一。我的意思是，难道我们不能称……他们不是终身仁慈独裁者（benevolent dictators for life）。核心团队是会轮换的，而且没有哪一个独裁者，他们对项目也没有绝对控制权，他们只能在摆在眼前的选项中进行抉择，他们在任何形态或形式上都不是终身仁慈独裁者，所以他们是仁慈的，他们是仁慈的画师（painters），我想
is the word that chand used. So benevolent painters. Painters are for the people that pick names for things. That's not the core team. There's one painter. That's my understanding. So it's benevolent. What do you replace the D with? And what do you replace the FL with?
这是钱德（Chand）用的词。所以是仁慈的画师。画师是指那些为事物起名字的人。那不是核心团队。只有一个画师。这是我的理解。所以它是仁慈的。你用什么来替换 D 呢？你又用什么来替换 FL 呢？
You don't need to. I want to. You don't need to. It's a bad model. It's an acronym. It's not a model. I don't know. I don't know. And what't need to. It's a bad model. It's an acronym. It's not a model. I don't know. I don't know.
你不需要替换。我想替换。你不需要。这是一个糟糕的模型。它是一个缩写。它不是一个模型。我不知道。我不知道。而且不需要。这是一个糟糕的模型。它是一个缩写。它不是一个模型。我不知道。我不知道。
And what did you say? They were core members? Core team. So they're benevolent core team members for an ephemeral amount of time. Yes. So what is that? That's B-C-T-M-E-T. That doesn't really roll off the tongue does it benevolent um deciders for now
那你刚才说什么来着？他们是核心成员？核心团队。所以他们是在一段短暂时间内存在的仁慈核心团队成员。是的。那是什么？那是 B-C-T-M-E-T。这读起来实在有点拗口，对吧？仁慈的……嗯……暂时的决策者（deciders for now）
except it can't be d because d is taken by dictator yeah i'm trying i'm trying to create an acronym that will work for bdFL. Benevolent decider is for... It should be... It's like a word that starts with L that's like a femoral. It can't be the same acronym because that's not going to make any sense. That's what we're doing. We're not acronyming BDFL. What's a word that starts with L? We're creating a new acronym.
除了它不能是 D，因为 D 被独裁者（dictator）占用了。是的，我在尝试，我在尝试创建一个适用于 BDFL 的缩写。仁慈的决策者是……它应该是一个……就像一个以 L 开头的词，意思是短暂的。它不能是同一个缩写，因为那没有任何意义。这就是我们正在做的。我们不是在为 BDFL 套用缩写。有什么以 L 开头的词吗？我们在创建一个新的缩写。
Scrabble boy. Scrabble boy. Give me a word that starts with L. Call me Scrabble boy. Yeah, it means ephemeral. It's B something FN. Benevolent something for now. Leader?
拼字游戏男孩。拼字游戏男孩。给我一个以 L 开头的词。叫我拼字游戏男孩。是的，它的意思是短暂的。是 B 开头什么的 FN。暂时的仁慈什么的（Benevolent something for now）。领袖（Leader）？
Or it should just be T. B-T-F-N. Benevolent team for now. Yeah, benevolent team for now. With like a mini C that we don't put in the acronym. Sure. Or you can just call it core team.
或者它应该直接是 T。B-T-F-N。暂时的仁慈团队（Benevolent team for now）。是的，暂时的仁慈团队。带有一个我们不放进缩写里的微型 C。当然。或者你可以直接叫它核心团队。
No. B. You know. This is going to catch on. We're creating a new acronym that's going to become just as popular. I disavow this acronym. No.
不。B。你知道的。这个要流行起来了。我们正在创造一个新的缩写，它会变得同样受欢迎。我否认这个缩写。不。
Yes. Yeah. Is there anything else we want to say? What are the, so, you know, I'll probably title these Rust, no, Carbon versus C++ versus Rust, because that's clickbaity. Or is that bad? Should we name it something else, these episodes should we name them uh that was a pretty good title just call it carbon just go just carbon we should bring yeah we should bring kate on you know we don't have to do our strategizing live no we don't but we're we do what we want um and and we should also bring uh sean on to talk about uh his keynote and also
是的。是的。还有什么我们想说的吗？那么，你知道，我可能会把这些命名为《Rust，不，Carbon 对比 C++ 对比 Rust》，因为这样比较吸引眼球（clickbaity）。还是说这样不好？我们应该把它命名为别的吗？这些节目我们应该命名为……那是个相当不错的名字，就叫 Carbon，直接就叫 Carbon。我们应该把……是的，我们应该把凯特请来，你知道的，我们没必要现场进行战略规划。不，我们不用，但我们想做什么就做什么。而且，而且我们还应该请肖恩来谈谈他的主旨演讲，以及
um the vowel language which didn't get announced well we should bring dave on to talk about the language because dave is the person that's the the creator okay we'll bring we'll bring everyone on we'll bring kate on we'll bring sean on. We'll bring Dave on. Although Sean and Dave have already been on the podcast. We need to diversify our people that we're bringing on here. True story. Bryce is on his phone right now. How can you tell? Because you're staring down at your hands.
嗯，Val 语言，它并没有被很好地宣发。嗯，我们应该请戴夫（Dave）来谈谈这门语言，因为戴夫才是创作者。好吧，我们会把大家都请来，我们会请凯特来，我们会请肖恩来。我们会请戴夫来。虽然肖恩和戴夫都已经上过播客了。我们需要让请来的嘉宾更多元化一些。实话实说。布莱斯现在正在看手机。你怎么知道的？因为你正盯着自己的手。
And I assume you're not just... There's a dog here, dude. Which requires you to be at your hands. And I assume you're not just... There's a dog here, dude. Which requires you to be on your phone? I'm not on my phone. I'm petting the dog. You literally just admitted to being on your phone. You said, how can you tell? Because I wanted to know why you thought I was on my phone.
而且我猜你不仅仅是……这里有一只狗，老兄。这需要你把手放在……而且我猜你不仅仅是……这里有一只狗，老兄。这需要你一直玩手机吗？我没有玩手机。我在撸狗。你刚才 literalmente 承认自己在玩手机了。你说，“你怎么知道的？”因为我想知道为什么你觉得我在玩手机。
Oh. Looney, come here and be my alibi loony don't knock because then she barks hang on one second i have to figure out where my dog is all right it's just me and you listener probably probably why did you wake the dog up what a guy I'll tell you my co-host she was asleep and you woke her up
哦。露尼（Looney），过来当我的不在场证明。露尼，别撞到门，不然她会叫的。等一下，我得弄清楚我的狗在哪里。好吧，现在只有我和你，听众。大概吧。你为什么把狗吵醒了？真是个家伙。我告诉你，我的联合主持人，她当时睡着了，而你把她吵醒了。
yes I did wake her up but I need to know where she was she figured out how to open the apartment door today like twice in a row so but I need to know where she was. She figured out how to open the apartment door today, like twice in a row. So until I figure out how that happened, I need to keep an eye on her. We will put in the show notes,
对，我是把她吵醒了，但我得知道她在哪里。她今天居然学会了怎么打开公寓门，连续开了两次，所以我得知道她在哪里。她今天居然学会了怎么打开公寓门，连续开了两次，所以在我弄清楚这是怎么发生之前，我得盯着她。我们会在节目说明里放上，
picture of the dog, very cute picture of the dog. All right. In our last few minutes here, do you want to, before we do our full blown CPP North review with Kate, pending that she agrees to come on the podcast, anything you'd like to recap from CPP North
狗狗的照片，非常可爱的狗狗照片。好吧。在我们这最后几分钟里，你想不想，在我们对 CPP North 进行全面回顾（邀请凯特作为嘉宾，取决于她是否同意上播客）之前，关于 CPP North 你有什么想总结的吗？
outside of the Carbon keynote and Sean's keynote? How did your talks go? How was the food? Apparently, I've just heard from everyone that like the food was unreal and apparently that's what people care most about at conferences shouldn't you shouldn't you know that because you as program chair would of course be at all the conference functions and events you know like lightning talks and the dinners because you know like maybe there was a lightning talk about
除了 Carbon 的主旨演讲和肖恩的主旨演讲之外？你的演讲怎么样？伙食怎么样？显然，我刚刚从所有人那里听说，那里的食物简直好得不可思议，显然这也是人们在会议上最关心的事情。难道你，难道你不知道吗？因为你作为节目主席，当然会参加所有的会议职能和活动，你知道的，比如闪电演讲（lightning talks）和晚宴，因为你知道，也许有一场关于
people running you know that's something that's really close to your heart you would you wouldn't want to you really poorly executed that because like i would i thought i was like yeah okay i can give my thoughts as well but i'm asking you but it only started to make sense what the point you were trying to make when you got to the tail end of your explanation there was a lightning talk about running at c++ conferences but connor missed it do you listen to do you know why he missed it because he was running at a c++ conference he went and did did an 8k yes there was a 8k race and it that's not like a distance of race that i've heard of before like i it's a number that i know it's actually typically the um men's cross-country distance um why am i qualifying men because they have different distances and cross-country for
人们跑步的闪电演讲，那是离你的心非常近的事情，你不会想……你对此执行得非常糟糕，因为我就像是在想：“好吧，我也可以发表我的看法。”但我是在问你。直到你解释到尾声时，我才开始明白你想表达的重点是什么。有一场关于在 C++ 会议上跑步的闪电演讲，但康纳错过了。你知道他为什么错过吗？因为他在 C++ 会议上跑步。他去参加了，跑了个 8K。是的，有一场 8K 比赛，这不是我以前听说过的比赛距离。我认得这个数字，它实际上通常是男子越野赛的距离。为什么我要限定是男子？因为他们在男子和女子越野赛中有不同的距离，许多人对此表示：“为什么？”在田径运动的所有其他项目中，又不是说是男子 100 米短跑，而女子是 70 米短跑。但在越野赛中，出于某种原因，他们决定把它们弄成不同的。比起跑步更不重要的是，当时气温是 34 度，体感像 40 度。对于我们的美国听众来说，所以是的，那些不是……40 度我觉得大约是 100 华氏度，这非常热。所以，好吧，谷歌翻译，把 40 度假温度翻译成美国温度。不，它听不懂我的话。摄氏度转华氏度。是 104 度，这跟 100 度很不一样。就像我说的，大约是 100 度。我想听众一定对我的翻译能力印象深刻。不管怎样，重点是，天气热得离谱，而且，是的，天气这么热的时候大概不应该去跑步比赛。不管怎样，我同意，我希望
women and men which many people have been like, why? Every other event in track and field, it's not like it's the men's 100-meter dash and it's the women's 70-meter dash. But in cross-country, for some reason, they decided to make them different. Less important than the run was the fact that it was 34 degrees and felt like 40 and for our american listeners so yeah those are not 40 is i think roughly like 100 degrees fahrenheit um which which is very hot so okay google translate 40 degrees fake temperature into american temperature no it doesn't understand me celsius to fill in light it's 104 degrees which is very different than 100 degrees that's like i said roughly 100 i think the listener is impressed with my translation abilities anyways the point is it was ridiculously hot and um yeah probably shouldn't be running races when it's that hot anyways i i agree i would prefer
你不要死掉，那会很棒。不过是的，我确实错过了，一些，一些闪电演讲。但不管怎样，回到你的 CPP North 回顾，请开始，你只有五分钟。哦，嗯，我觉得这是一次很棒的会议。我还应该说些什么？嗯，我真的很喜欢你的演讲，也就是我赶上了的那 30 分钟，因为我以为它比实际开始时间晚了一个小时才开始。所以我去了健身房。真是个家伙。让我想想。我确实觉得食物相当、相当棒。
you to not die that would be great but yes i did miss uh some of the some of the lightning talks um but anyways back to your cpp north review go you got five minutes oh um i thought it was a great conference um what else am i supposed to say um i really enjoyed your talk the 30 minutes for which I showed up because I thought it started an hour later than it did. So I went to the gym. What a guy. Let's see. I did think the food was pretty, pretty awesome.
我很欣赏这些食物显然是由一个热爱加拿大的人精心挑选的。比如在第一天，有所有这些加拿大的零食，还有加拿大的垃圾食品，我真的很感激这些小细节里倾注的心思。我也非常喜欢所有的组织者都穿着全身的运动套装。听众朋友们，不用担心，节目里会有康纳穿着那身运动套装的照片。嗯，
I appreciated that the food was clearly selected by somebody who loved canada there was like on the first day there were all these like canadian snacks um and like canadian junk food and i just i appreciated the thought they went into the little details i also really liked that all the organizers had like full body tracksuits and don't worry, listener, there will be a picture of Connor in that sweatsuit. Um, uh,
在节目里。我的意思是，我其实从来没穿过整套运动套装。嗯，但他会穿上整套运动套装拍张照片。绝对的。
on the, in the show. I mean, I actually never wore the full sweatsuit. Um, but he's going to put the full sweatsuit on, take a picture. Absolutely.
不会的。嗯，我想每个人都穿了整套运动套装，除了我。我只是，在大夏天我没法穿那种裤子，就……我有团队精神，但是，嗯，我觉得这是一个很强的节目。嗯，是的，有很多演讲我都相当喜欢。嗯，等等，让我想想，我某处有笔记。
Won't. Um, I think everybody wore the full sweatsuit except for me. I just, I can't wear pants in the middle of the summer that are like, I am a team player, but, uh, I thought it was a strong program. Um, yeah, there was a lot of talks that I quite enjoyed. Um, hang on, let me, I have notes somewhere.
我某处有笔记。你去了英国，嗯，你去了 C on C，而我们甚至都还没谈过那个。我也觉得那是一场执行得非常出色的会议。我觉得 CPP NC 和 CPP North 都执行得非常出色。我对会议的所有细节、AV 设置、餐饮，以及所有运行得非常顺畅的环节都印象深刻。而且我很喜欢那些演讲。
I have notes somewhere. You went to the UK and, uh, you went to C on C, and we haven't even talked about that. Which I also thought was a very well-executed conference. I thought both CPP NC and CPP North were very well-executed. I was very impressed with just all the details of the conference, the AV setup, the catering, just everything really well run. And I liked the talks.
是的，关于那些会议的方方面面我都非常满意。好吧。是的。你在 CPP North 上最喜欢哪些演讲？因为我，我当然看过自己喜欢的演讲，我只是有点记不清了。可能吧，呃，对听众来说，说肖恩的演讲可能是我的最爱，这可能没什么意思。它也可能是最引人深思的，因为他提到了一件事：他说 C++ 和 VAL 都是按定义高效的语言（efficient by definition languages），而另一类语言则是按优化高效的语言（efficient by optimization）。
Yeah, everything about those conferences I was very happy with. All righty. Yeah. What were your favorite talks at uh cpb north um because i i i know i saw talks that i enjoyed i'm just having trouble remembering probably i mean it's not going to be interesting to the listener to say that sean's talk um was probably my favorite. It also probably was the most thought provocative because of one thing that he mentioned where he said that C++ and VAL are both efficient by definition languages versus the other category of languages which are efficient by optimization.
我以前从未听说过这种编程语言分类法。而且我在肖恩的主旨演讲后没机会跟他交流，因为我觉得他讲完后直接就累瘫了，毕竟会议很长。他甚至在演讲开始时就提到自己感觉不太舒服，还去做了个快速检测，结果是阴性的。所以，是的，演讲结束后没能有机会和他交流。但我认为这确实是，是的，非常有趣。
And I had never heard that taxonomy of programming languages. And I didn't get a chance to talk to Sean after his keynote because I think he just crashed afterwards because it was a long conference. And he even mentioned at the beginning of the talk that he wasn't feeling super well and went and did a rapid test, was negative. So yeah, he didn't get a chance to talk to him right after. But I think that's just, yeah, it's very interesting
到底什么才叫按定义高效。我们把它留到另一个播客里再谈吧。但我只是觉得这个想法是，你知道，不，我们会把它留到这个播客的不同单集里。哦，我是说不同的……这么说是因为康纳还有别的播客。哦，是的，我们会在这一期节目里讨论它。也许当肖恩作为嘉宾来到节目时我们会讨论它，因为，是的，我对这种划分或这种分类法确实有一些疑问。在肖恩的演讲之后，我非常喜欢法蒂玛（Fatima）的演讲。法蒂玛曾是我第一家公司的主管，她做了一场题为……的演讲。
what exactly does it mean to be efficient by definition. We'll save that for a different podcast. But I just think the idea is that you know well no we'll save it for this podcast a different episode oh did i say a different say that because connor has other podcasts oh yeah we will we will talk about it on this episode maybe we'll talk about it when when sean comes on um because yeah i do have questions about about that delineation or that taxonomy um after sean's i really liked fatima's talk um fatima used to be my old manager at my first company and she gave a talk called um i never got a chance to corner her and get all of the young goner stories unfortunately um yeah i'm sure we
我从来没有机会堵住她并打听所有关于小康纳的故事，真遗憾。嗯，我确信我们
just have to come back to cpp north next year i heard she was considering submitting another talk but her talk was about programming with kids and um she has a couple kids and has been sort of testing out different programming environments like scratch with her kid and um had a bunch of basically links and recommendations for a ton of resources that i had never even heard about um not that i have kids but um if at any point i do it would be cool to experiment with those things i mean tony's talks are always good he gave yeah i enjoyed His was very creative. Yeah, had a bunch of Beatle references and lots of good laughs in his talk. Looking forward to seeing part two of that one,
明年只需再来一次 CPP North。我听说她当时在考虑提交另一场演讲，但她的演讲是关于和孩子们一起编程的。嗯，她有几个孩子，一直在和孩子一起测试不同的编程环境，比如 Scratch，并且基本上准备了一堆链接和推荐，涵盖了大量我甚至从未听说过的资源。倒不是说我有孩子，不过，嗯，如果我在任何时候有了孩子，去尝试那些东西会挺酷的。我是说，托尼（Tony）的演讲总是很精彩。他做了……是的，我挺喜欢他的演讲的。他的演讲非常有创意。是的，里面有一堆披头士乐队（Beatle）的梗，他的演讲里也有很多欢声笑语。期待看到那一场的第二部分，
which I think he said offline was going to be value-oriented programming part two types. Wow. Wow. Way to spoiler Tony's talks, man. I just gave the title. I didn't spoil anything. That time I was definitely on my phone, and I'm going to admit to that because my phone was visible on the webcam. But the dog is here. The dog is here. You see dog right there. There's a dog.
我想他在场外说过那将会是面向值编程（value-oriented programming）第二部分：类型。哇。哇。真会剧透托尼的演讲啊，老兄。我只是说出了标题。我什么都没剧透。那一次我绝对是在玩手机，我要承认这一点，因为我的手机在网络摄像头里露出来了。不过狗在这里。狗在这里。你看到那里的狗了吧。有一只狗。
All right. Well, with that, I think it's time to wrap this up. What I was going to say is that you missed my talk, and I'm actually giving it live streaming on YouTube in T-minus 27 minutes. Probably. That's why you got to go. Probably. Well, I'll be in the gym. So I guess I'll listen.
好吧，话虽如此，我觉得是时候结束了。我本来想说的是，你错过了我的演讲，而我实际上将在 T 减 27 分钟内在 YouTube 上进行直播。大概吧。这就是你得走了的原因。大概吧。好吧，我会去健身房的。所以我想我会去听的。
Just like send me a reminder. Yeah, for those that are listening on this podcast uh it's not 27 minutes from when this podcast correct it will have been like two weeks ago but it'll definitely be in the show but wouldn't it be amazing if connor pulled that off if if wouldn't it be amazing if 27 minutes from when you're hearing this connor was live streaming? Assuming that you listen to it. I was going to say, you see what the obvious flaw with that is, is that most people do not.
就给我发个提醒吧。是的，对于那些收听这个播客的人来说，这并不是距离这个播客录制过去 27 分钟，正确的时间应该是在大约两周前，但它肯定会出现在节目中。不过，如果康纳真的做到了，那不是很神奇吗？如果在你听到这话的 27 分钟后康纳正在直播，那不是很神奇吗？假设你在收听的话。我本想说，你知道这其中明显的漏洞是什么吗，那就是大多数人并没有在听。
Yeah. But everybody, everybody, all of our listeners listen as soon as a new episode is published, of course. I can guarantee you that that's definitely not the case. But thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的。但每个人，每个人，我们所有的听众在一有新单集发布时就会立刻收听，当然。我可以向你保证，这绝对不是真的。但感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢本期节目，并祝你有美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可留下评论。